En agosto del 2009 mi oficina capoteó dos escándalos serios.
El primero fue el arresto, juicio y sentencia
y la encarcelación subsiguiente del muy popular alcalde de Detroit.
El segundo causó el cierre del laboratorio criminal de la policía de Detroit.
Pensaba que nada más podía salir mal.
Entonces sonó el teléfono.
(Risas)
Era el subjefe de mi unidad de víctimas especiales,
quien estaba jadeando en el otro teléfono.
Dijo, "Jefa, nunca creerá lo que acabo de ver".
Tenía un mal presentimiento,
porque sabía por instinto
que Detroit se preparaba para su tercer escándalo serio,
en poco más de un año.
Me dijo que acababa de visitar lo que pensaba que era un almacén abandonado
donde el departamento de policía de Detroit almacenaba evidencias.
Adentro había 11 341 grupos de pruebas forenses de violaciones
abandonadas sin examinar,
Algunas eran de los años 80.
Y algunas ahora tienen más de 40 años.
Estos grupos de pruebas estaban en fundas de plástico grandes y negras
y barriles de petróleo vacíos.
Cada grupo de pruebas representaba una víctima
en su mayoría mujeres
que habían sufrido una agresión sexual violenta.
Cada una aguantó voluntariamente horas durante el procedimiento
para obtener pruebas forenses de violación,
con la esperanza de que, como resultado, encontrarían su perpetrador.
Y desconocido para todas ellas, todos ellos,
los 11 341 grupos de pruebas nunca fueron examinados.
No puedo empezar a describir... ¡oh!
Y a propósito, antes de seguir,
durante estos 40 años,
estos perpetradores seguían agrediendo con impunidad.
No puedo decir ni describir lo indignada, enojada y furiosa que estaba.
Yo misma fui víctima de agresión sexual,
hace muchas décadas, cuando estudiaba Derecho.
También soy madre de tres chicas, una de 21 años y gemelas de 9 años.
Si es que aún yo pudiera estar más escandalizada, aún lo estuve más,
al saber, que los grupos de pruebas forenses más antiguos
uno de los más antiguos, pertenecía a una niña de 8 años.
Les contaré su historia, pero la llamaré Natasha.
El 2 de enero de 1990 Natasha estaba en su casa
cuando un hombre llamó a la puerta.
Este hombre tenía conocimiento de su barrio
y de las idas y venidas de su familia,
pero Natasha no le conocía.
La dijo que su abuela, la única madre que había conocido,
había tenido un accidente terrible
y yacía en un sofá en su casa, llamándola.
Aterrada porque iba a perder su abuela, salió con él.
Pero por supuesto, todos sabemos que su abuela no estaba allá.
Cuando había aislado a Natasha, quien tenía ocho años,
empezó a violarla violentamente.
La violó con su boca, sus dedos y su pene.
Incluso forzó su pene en su boca.
Cuando terminó, ordenó a Natasha vestirse,
se vistió también,
y le puso una venda en los ojos.
Y la encaminó a una fábrica a la orilla del barrio.
La preguntó después de quitarle la venda,
si sabía cómo volver a casa desde allá.
Cuando indicó que sí sabía, la dejó ir y se fue.
Se reportó la violación de Natasha de inmediato,
y se realizó el procedimiento para obtener pruebas de violación.
El proceso para la obtención de pruebas de violación
aterroriza y traumatiza a mujeres adultas.
¿Pueden imaginar cómo fue para una niñita de segundo,
que todavía llevaba coletas y todavía creía en Papá Noel,
pasar por ese procedimiento de recogida de pruebas?
El grupo de pruebas de Natasha se quedó en el estante en el almacén abandonado
26 años.
Pamela, con 19 años...
La llamaré Pamela, no es su verdadero nombre,
ella con 19 años caminaba por la calle
después de haber estado en casa de su novio.
Alguien la agarró por detrás,
y sintió lo que pensaba que era una pistola, en su costado.
Se la llevó a una casa abandonada,
a una habitación en aquella casa llena de basura.
Cada vez que intentaba resistir,
él la pegó en la cara y cabeza.
La violó violentamente en el piso de aquella habitación
llena de basura.
Cuando terminó,
se puso la ropa,
robó su dinero y salió caminando.
Pamela también reportó su violación de inmediato.
También pasó por el procedimiento de recogida de pruebas de violación.
Y como las de Natasha, sus pruebas forenses quedaron en el estante 15 años.
Criminales, como los que violaron a Natasha y Pamela,
a menudo dejan su ADN en la escena del crimen.
Pero para una víctima de violación, su cuerpo es la escena del crimen.
Muchos escogen pasar por este proceso que dura horas
que requiere que se peine, pruebe y fotografíe
cada cm y cada orificio del cuerpo de la víctima.
Todo esto después de un asalto sexual violento.
La razón por la cual la mayoría hace esto, pasan por este procedimiento.
es porque quieren que los científicos forenses estudien las evidencias.
Y ojalá vengan con un perfil genético
que ayudará a identificar su perpetrador.
Una vez crean que los forenses tienen el perfil genético,
lo introducen en el CODIS, para con suerte encontrar su igual.
El CODIS está lleno de perfiles de personas arrestadas
y/o condenados por algunos delitos prescritos.
Si de hecho se hace un perfil y se introduce en el CODIS,
esto puede ayudar a identificar a un perpetrador en minutos.
CODIS significa sistema indexado combinado de ADN.
Ahora ¿cómo llegamos hasta acá?
Detroit no tenía dinero.
En el momento en que se encontraron las pruebas, el costo de examinar
cada grupo de pruebas ascendía hasta USD 1500
Entonces, hagan el cálculo sobre los costos que se iban a generar.
Además,
en el 2009, cuatro años tras encontrar las pruebas de las violaciones,
Detroit iba a convertirse en el municipio más grande en la historia de EE. UU.
declarado en bancarrota.
No sabíamos qué hacer.
Pero no solo eso.
Cuando empezamos a estudiar e investigar cómo pudo haber pasado esto,
descubrimos que había más problemas además de los asuntos financieros.
Durante las décadas que los grupos de pruebas estuvieron en el almacén,
descubrimos que hubo varios cambios de liderazgo de la policía,
con diferentes prioridades y diferentes agendas.
Había un entrenamiento para oficiales de delitos sexuales muy inadecuado
en el departamento en general.
Tenían una falta de personal crónica,
y otros problemas de recursos.
Y culparon a la víctima sistemáticamente
cuando las víctimas iban a reportar sus crímenes.
Esa es la cultura de la violación.
Y debido a que culparon a las víctimas
por haber sufrido una agresión sexual violenta,
ridiculizaron a algunas de las víctimas
hasta lograr que no continuaran con la denuncia.
El caso es que 11 341 grupos de pruebas de violación estaban en el estante.
Yo quería transparencia.
Me pregunté ¿cómo podemos evitar que esto se propague?
No quiero hacer todo el trabajo y cinco, diez años más tarde,
tener el mismo problema.
En ese entonces, los oficiales de policía tenían el propio criterio
sobre si y cuándo
iban a entregar las evidencias forenses,
cualquiera de ellas en su jurisdicción.
Eso tenía que cambiar.
Teníamos que eliminar la arbitrariedad de los oficiales de policía,
y aprobar leyes estatales
para asegurarnos de que cada grupo de pruebas de violación de cada víctima
fuera cursada de inmediato.
También sabía que necesitábamos un sistema
para hacer a todos honestos y responsables,
para saber en cualquier momento
dónde estaban los grupos de pruebas violación
La respuesta fue sencilla.
Piensen en los cientos de miles
quizás millones de paquetes,
que transporta una compañía de logística.
Los escanean y rastrean,
y saben dónde están en cada momento,
desde el momento en que los guardan en el almacén,
hasta el momento en que el paquete llega a la puerta del comprador.
¿Por qué no podríamos hacer eso para los grupos de pruebas?
No quise reinventar la rueda.
Así que contacté a UPS.
UPS, en dos semanas, solo dos semanas,
desde la primera reunión con UPS,
había creado un gran plan
donde involucraron a todos los implicados.
Policías, fiscales, centros sanitarios,
enfermeros forenses, hospitales,
personal del laboratorio abogados de víctimas,
sabrían donde estaban las pruebas de violación en cualquier momento.
Enviaron un equipo de expertos
y se dispersaron por todo Detroit, hablaron con los implicados
y desarrollaron un plan,
y estudiaron la trazabilidad de un grupo de pruebas forenses
desde el momento en que recogieron las pruebas,
hasta que las examinaron en el laboratorio
y las devolvieron a la policía.
También desarrollaron un portal basado en web
donde todos los implicados tenían acceso para ver dónde estaba
un grupo de pruebas en cualquier momento.
UPS tenía la tecnología,
UPS sabía cómo usar la tecnología para resolver nuestro problema,
y nosotros no.
Lo lanzamos, nosotros, nosotros,
UPS y la oficina del fiscal,
(Risas)
lanzamos este programa piloto en Detroit.
Y empezamos este proceso el 28 de enero, 2015,
hasta el 25 de mayo de 2016.
Y durante este período de tiempo
--recuerden, no estamos hablando de los que encontramos,
porque ya se habían almacenado--
trabajamos con todo grupo de pruebas nuevas llegadas desde el 28 de enero 2015.
Y sabíamos dónde estaba cada grupo de pruebas de violación.
Durante los 16 meses de este proyecto, no perdimos ni un solo grupo de pruebas.
Ni uno solo.
Sabíamos dónde estaban todos.
(Aplausos)
Este proyecto siguió hasta que en el estado de Michigan,
los oficiales electos del gobierno estatal,
se dieran cuenta de todo lo que hacía UPS
y todo lo que hacía mi oficina.
Y decidieron que iban a usar fondos estatales
para desarrollar un sistema de rastreo para todo el estado.
No solo en Detroit, sino un sistema de todo el estado.
Ojalá el sistema esté funcionando pronto.
Pero me encantaba trabajar con UPS.
Me encantaba su innovación, lo rápido que trabajaban,
Me encantaba su manera poco convencional de resolver un problema común y corriente,
cuya solución debe ser sencilla.
Después de trabajar con ellos
sabiendo que una compañía
trabajaba en el problema,
pudimos avanzar.
Hemos estado trabajando en esto por nueve años.
Y hace 9 años
rescatamos esos grupos de pruebas de violación del almacén.
Desde entonces el almacén ha sido derrumbado.
Pero todos los grupos de pruebas o han sido examinados,
o están en los últimos pasos de ser examinados.
Todavía tenemos mucho que hacer
en relación a la investigación y el procesamiento de esos casos,
pero el asunto de los grupos de pruebas en relación a su examen se acabó.
A partir del 28 de junio, 2018,
nuestro CODIS ha mostrado e identificado a 2600 sospechosos.
Hemos identificado 861 violadores en serie.
Solo en este proyecto.
Eso significa que 861 acusados potenciales
han violado dentro del proyecto dos veces o más.
Y de 50 a 75 de ellos han violado de 10 a 15 veces cada uno.
En una ciudad, en un estado.
Además, los resultados del CODIS que tenemos
tienen tentáculos a escenas de crimen,
con enlaces en 40 estados en EE. UU.
40 de los 50 estados tienen enlaces a los grupos de pruebas de violación.
Desde Alaska a Florida
y desde Maine a las partes más al sur de California.
Un mar a brillante mar, hilo de coincidencias en el CODIS.
Natasha ahora tiene 36 años.
Cuando supo del trabajo que hacíamos con los grupos de pruebas de violación,
contactó mi oficina, la oficina del fiscal de Wayne County.
Finalmente, sus pruebas forenses fueron examinadas
e identificaron a Paul Warwick.
Mientras tanto, Paul Warwick había violado a dos mujeres más.
Una en el estado de Colorado.
Ahora Paul Warwick está cumpliendo una condena
en la prisión de Michigan,
con una pena de 15 a 40 años.
(Aplausos)
El grupo de pruebas de Pamela también fue examinado,
Y la coincidencia de sus resultados en el CODIS hizo posible
identificar a Bernard Peterson.
Mientras tanto, Bernard Peterson había violado a 10 mujeres más.
Cada una de las mujeres tenía su grupo de pruebas de violación.
Y cada uno de estos grupos de pruebas estaban el estante al lado del de Pamela
con un número diferente de años.
Bernard Peterson ahora está cumpliendo una condena
en la prisión de Michigan,
simultáneamente, es decir, al mismo tiempo
de 60 a 90 años y 90 a 125 años,
por las violaciones que cometió.
(Aplausos)
Todavía hay mucho qué hacer.
Y necesitamos desesperadamente la ayuda del sector privado.
Necesitamos la ayuda de la industria tecnológica.
Para ayudarnos, bueno no, queremos que desarrollen
sistemas de gestión de información,
para que nos podamos comunicar
y parar a estos perpetradores
que violan, mutilan y matan con impunidad.
También necesitamos ayuda de aquellos de Uds.
con experiencia en mercadotecnia y publicidad.
Los necesitamos, los necesitamos desesperadamente,
para diseñar una campaña para nuestros niños y otras personas,
con el fin de cambiar la cultura de las víctimas de violación
quienes están demasiado asustadas para denunciar por los que les pudiera pasar.
UPS era una compañía, como dije.
Nos ayudó con su innovación,
y revolucionaron cómo hacer el seguimiento de los grupos de pruebas de violación.
Cada aspecto de nuestras vidas está rastreado.
Cada Me gusta, cada humor,
el historial de compras, el de navegación, el de lectura
todo nuestro historial del internet está rastreado hoy en día.
¿Qué pasa si podemos rastrear las actividades y las idas y venidas
de los criminales que cometen crímenes?
Tal como gente rastrea cada aspecto de nuestras vidas.
En el 2015 la Casa Blanca de Obama
y el Departamento de Justicia
estimaron en a 400 000 los grupos de pruebas no examinados y abandonados
en todo el país.
400 000.
Esa es una pandemia nacional.
Sabemos dónde están muchos de los grupos de pruebas.
Nuestras investigaciones mostraron
que las mujeres fueron violadas esperando en sus autos, esperando a amigos,
camino al trabajo, de vuelta del trabajo,
en estaciones de gasolina, en centros comerciales.
Y una de los primeros casos que hicimos
cuando empezamos a probar los grupos de pruebas de violación,
era un hombre que entró por la ventana
entró en la cama y violó a una mujer en la cama con sus dos niños.
La violó mientras estaba en la cama con sus dos niños.
Cada vez que veo una víctima de violación que entra en mi oficina,
porque abren su caso
o está siendo entrevistada por el fiscal,
o se está preparando para un caso,
miro sus ojos y pienso,
no tenía que ser una de las que violaron.
No tenía que ser una de las víctimas.
Y tal vez no lo sería, si hubieran de inmediato examinado los grupos de pruebas.
¿Cuántas más Pamelas hay en el mundo?
¿Cuántas más Natashas hay en el mundo?
Nunca lo sabremos.
Pero lo que sí sé es que Uds. tienen la tecnología,
saben cómo usarla
y nos pueden ayudar a resolver el problema de la acumulación de grupos de pruebas.
Gracias.
(Aplauso)